president and CEO of the foundation for
individual rights and expression and
co-author of the book The cancelling of
the American mind Greg
lukanov GRE how are you sir great to
meet
you thank you sir well you you know why
you're here this week this is the week
that they called the heads of the U
Harvard and Penn and MIT they could have
called a number of other colleges like
my alma Cornell there a bunch of
up there these days too uh but
these were the three who were called and
this is really what you've been writing
about for a long time this is what your
book is about we quoted you your
organization fire a few weeks ago in an
editorial because it was about campuses
and where the Free Speech was what first
of all what does fire stand for the the
foundation for individual rights and
expression we were're 25 years old this
year okay oh wow I didn't know you're on
that okay
so so I remember when we did the piece
the at the absolute bottom of the the
list NE they got a negative score was
Harvard Harvard and right next to them
was pen yep so these are two of the
colleges who are now on team Hamas
yeah is that a coincidence or what is
the connection well this is I mean they
kind of got what they had coming because
they they had to go in front of Congress
and convince them that they actually now
were good on free speech and nobody
believed them Harvard you know it earned
its position dead and I always give the
example you know when it comes to
Harvard Carol hooven for example she's
someone who was on a show she was pring
a book about testosterone she made the
point that we should be uh kind and
compassionate toward towards trans
people use their pronouns but we can't
pretend that biological sex isn't real
and the DI administrator you at Harvard
you know started complaining about it
suddenly students are boycotting her
class and writing petitions and she was
uh she left Harvard because because of
the environment and so nobody could
actually take seriously the idea that
they they believe in free speech mean
while the president appen after her
disastrous performance comes out and
says oh you know what we're not actually
going to have our policies match
constitutional standards anymore and
it's like no you've been letting
administrators uh clamp down on speech
for decades now this will only make it
worse okay but the connection between
yeah supporting Hamas yeah and the lack
of free speech yeah let's get into that
because I want to read this is what uh
the congresswoman who was grilling Al
Alise stefanic who has her own issue
with speech by the
way
okay New York State used to be a normie
okay but she loves Trump now um she
asked the pen person does calling for
the genocide of Jews violates penens
rules or code of conduct yes or no now
I'm a free speech person like you are
yeah I'm also team Israel yeah so let's
just get real about this sure calling
for the genocide of Jews one of them I
think it was the pen person said I've
not heard that m in other words how
explicit is it because when I break down
the phrases that I hear first there's
the in there a lot of people who say you
shouldn't say that I disagree free
speech inata that's one of those vague
terms like Jihad it probably means
violence but you know what it's just
Uprising whatever give you a better okay
then there's from The River To The Sea
yep okay that's a little more genocide
but you
know let's give the benefit of that
could be well we just want the Jews to
move not
die where they're going to move to I'm
going to address that next week for our
our season finale is next week by the
way it it's
true as you can see the excitement is
building and then there's a phrase by
any means necessary okay
now now I'm kind of peeing my pants
yeah right and I'm not even Je Jewish
but come
on by any means necessary that so where
do you draw the line here and what do
you say is free speech and what should
not be allowed well we the First
Amendment actually gives a lot of
guidance on this and one thing that's
been horrifying over the past month is
seeing a lot of unprotected speech on
campus we're seeing things that cross
the line into true threats
discriminatory harassment we're seeing
things that actually aren't protected
but uh merely expressive offensive
expression like saying inata that is
absolute absolutely protected but can
saying things like that be part of a
pattern of threats or harassment of
course it can be and it was kind of
embarrassing to watch these University
presidents of the top institutions in
the country not being able to answer
that clearly right see what irks me is
that look I'm always going to be on the
side of as far as you can push free
speech and and of course as you say
there's already limits to some Life
Speech violence and St where you fire in
a crowd at there okay so it's not
absolute what bothers me is the double
standard oh my God yeah
that can you IM I mean okay say they
don't want to say kill the Jews but I
certainly have heard chanted the
Jews the Jews can you imagine
saying the and any other I'm not
going to say any other group because
they'll they'll CL clip the tape and
I'll live with that
forever
but I
just I cannot think of any other group
that you could say the blank and
and have it be acceptable the double
standards on campus we talk about this
in canceling we talk about this at fire
all the time the double standards are
astounding but you have to have them um
when you have policies like this because
if they actually enforce them against
everybody they wouldn't last a second
yeah I you know I I I honestly think the
kids I think they're you know that
phrase useful idiots
yeah the the bigger Scandal here is that
these are the biggest most esteemed
colleges in the country and they've
raised a bunch of IDI
you